I'm Alexander Rose I'm the director of
the long now foundation as some of you
know who come to these talks every month
we do a little short film before each
talk usually we call a long short this
is a short term film that exemplifies
long term thinking our long short this
month is called pixel can we have it
cute all right enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'm Joe Alton director of
community engagement here at YB CA and
we really want to extend a warm welcome
to all of you who are here so maybe in
the spirit of a game we'll just start it
like this in all of the chairs into the
chairs there are if you were to look
underneath there are stars and if you
happen to be the lucky recipient of a
star that means you can pick between Y
be ca or a long now foundation
membership in many ways as I was just
saying hi we like you in that sense I
think I'll keep it basic this the the
basis of this partnership so far has
been coming for the last couple of years
where we've had where we started
initially with a beautiful who came here
for the Brian Eno project I see some
hands is great and global lives how many
people came out here for global lives
like so many of our artists in the art
that comes through here we take
inspiration from them from all of these
artists and sources to come through and
definitely long now foundation has been
one of these inspirations for us at YB
CA which is why we're so excited to be
working with them we're turning 18 next
year and in the ways that we're all
trying to grow up as an institution you
know we're really moving into an area
we're becoming a center for art and
ideas and in a way that's both
sustainable human scale and dynamic and
so we really believe that our
partnership with long now foundation
brings us a little closer to that so
with that in terms of inspiration a man
who requires little to no introduction I
will introduce Stuart brand known for
Whole Earth Catalog on long now
foundation and then also invite all of
you after the
wonderful talk to join us for a
reception mcgunn then debate I'm Joel
tan
[Applause]
Thank You Joel I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation product placement
it's a good book back in 1972 I wrote an
article for a rolling stone called
fnatic lights and symbolic death among
the computer bones and what I was
writing about was space war and hackers
40 years ago I was actually referring to
something that started in 1961 at MIT
and quickly generated this thing called
space war which was the only computer
what we would call videogame for like 10
years and it clearly was leaking out of
the many computers that it was on and
affecting the lives of everybody who
played it and since that time these
games have been leaking further and
further out of the machines into the
real world in this series we had Daniel
Suarez last year talking about his book
demon which was a great thriller of
exactly that theme that was fiction
tonight we get nonfiction Jesse Schell
[Applause]
hi Wow look at all these people um hey
can we get some rhythmic clapping like
um that's it thank you okay it's good
keep it going keep it going
it's not so fast we go
[Music]
[Music]
all right thank you that's not relevant
at all but I'm a very nervous speaker
and that helped calm me down a great
deal so so thank you thank you very much
for that okay so tonight my talk is
called visions of the game pocalypse and
in a way it's kind of a follow-up talk
how many people saw my dice talk on the
Internet right oh my gosh that's a lot
of people which is weird right because
I'm a college professor I'm not used to
people listening to me and then suddenly
like a million views on that video so
that was that was kind of unexpected for
me
I'm just for people who don't know who I
am just a quick background I'm the CEO
of a video game studio called shell
games we have about 50 people we operate
out of Pittsburgh Pennsylvania I have a
second studio in Austin I also teach at
Carnegie Mellon University at the
entertainment Technology Center there I
formerly was with Walt Disney
Imagineering designing interactive theme
park rides and I continue to work with
Disney quite a bit and still were saying
I wrote a book called the art of game
design and there's a kind of deck of
creativity cards that goes with it
and I'm very excited to announce just
yesterday we launched a digital version
of the cards on the Droid if anyone has
a droid and will get it out on the iPod
as soon as the Apple bureaucracy will
finish chewing on it anyway so this
other talk I gave back in February of in
short I'm going to kind of give you the
shortened version of it it was all about
the facts that that there's this huge
driver and a cultural force right now of
authenticity that people want things
that are more real and more connected
with reality and this has really kind of
gone into the game space quite a bit
real life and games have been kind of
reaching out to each other and
connecting in ways that we previously
hadn't hadn't seen and we've seen all
kinds of examples of it in games we have
all these Facebook games which are all
about your your real life playing with
friends in real
life we have the Wii and the Wii Fit
which are all about using your your body
you know and guitar here using real
music from the real world making kind of
real motions with the guitar and and and
video games involving real stuffed
animals every game is kind of leaning
towards reality at the same time reality
sort of is reaching reconned of reaching
back with all these different ways
people are giving you points and things
out in the world and so I kind of in
this talk I kind of cast forward and
said well where is this going
well you know what would the quicker the
future possibly look like and I
described something that I refer to as
the game pocalypse and the idea of the
game pocalypse is that is when every
second of your life you are actually
playing a game in some way and so I'm
gonna I'm gonna repeat kind of the the
final part of that talk cause it gives
some some sense of it so if you can
imagine where this where this all might
be going imagine that sometime in the
near future that you wake up in the
morning and you go to brush your teeth
and your toothbrush you know has
inexpensive sensors on it and it's you
know Wi-Fi connected because it's really
cheap to do that and so you know you go
to brush your teeth and it's like you
know good job here's some points you
know for brushing brushing your teeth
right and you end of course once you
brush your teeth a full three minutes
you know more bonus points because
that's the appropriate amount of time to
brush your teeth and hey you've brushed
your teeth every day this week twice a
day more bonus points for you and you
can use these bonus points on discounts
on toothpaste and things are gonna buy
anyway after grocery store and it sounds
stupid who would do this why well the
toothbrush people don't know the more
you brush your teeth the faster you use
the toothpaste the faster you use
toothbrushes the more them you're gonna
buy they're gonna want to incentivize
you to do it and so then you go to
breakfast and you know there's the
cornflakes and the old days used to read
the back of the box but not anymore now
you know there's a screen on the back of
the box and again it's Wi-Fi connected
in everything it's got a tilt sensor
because everybody likes tilt sensor so
it can tell when you tip the box so
here's ten points for eating cornflakes
and then you're playing the cornflakes
game on the back you know while you eat
and you get points to doing that
and then you can see a list and it's
connected to Facebook of course and you
can see all your friends who are also
you know eating cornflakes and playing
the cornflakes game and you just hey you
just got a score higher than all your
friends and okay bonus points because
you're doing best at that and then you
go to work and you're gonna get on the
bus and you're like the boss why would I
take the bus well you take the bus
because the government gives out you
know gives that bonus points you know
for people who take public transit so
you know hey good job and you're sitting
there on the bus and you're you know you
take out your little phone and you were
gonna play Tetris but instead you end up
playing coke trous because it's free
right we went from you know you know
$5.99 apps to $0.99 apps and now all the
apps are sponsored so they're all free
and so you're playing coke triste and
that reminds you oh you know I had this
dream last night I had a dream that my
mother was dancing with a giant Pepsi
can right that's kind of weird and then
you realize oh dah I'm using the rm2
tainment system and the REMS retainment
system you put in your ear before you go
to sleep at night it can sense when
you've entered REM sleep and it starts
whispering little messages in your ear
attempting to influence your dreams with
product placement messages and then you
take tests in the morning and if you can
guess what what product was in your you
know was putting your dreams that means
it's working and so they give you all
kinds of points and of course the more
you do it the more successful it works
because we train our dreams so you get
big points because you remembered that
it was a Pepsi ad in your dreams last
night so then you get to work on time
good job good job
and in fact you've been on time every
you know every day this week so you know
excellent job you and you you go to your
cube and then hey here's your cut you're
off your office mate and he's like check
it out check it out I got this new I got
this new tattoo using e ink you know I
got one of the e ink tattoos and you
know lets me change the tattoo do
whatever I want
and of course right now he's got it
hooked up to tattoo --gel Adsense right
and so that he gets you know he gets two
points and he gets money for like
putting ads on there and and you're
telling them that's really dumb because
everyone knows tattoo Google Adsense has
light sensors built in and if you have
your sleeve covering it up
you're not gonna get any points for that
and you show them yours which is lower
on the arms so it gets more light and
just then you realized your tattoos are
matching right now and so you say link
sync you know and that's points and then
he says he says pop-tarts because
they're ads for pop-tarts right and
heating your points for that and then
you do high five and then the body
electricity sensors can sense that we
did a high five and boom we go both get
points for that we both think that's
pretty great that we noticed the link
sync and you're like what is that stupid
thing but that's what's gonna happen is
we're gonna have these games designed to
make you notice advertisements right
they'll be fun but they make you notice
ads and this can be very important and
so it's time to go to lunch now all week
you've been having dr. peppers right and
so that was 10 points 10 points 10
points 10 points for dr. peppers but you
know there's a special with dr. peppers
this week if you have a 5th dr. pepper
you know you get boom big bonus points
and so of course you're gonna have one
at lunch but then after lunch you go
into a meeting and the meetings in
another building and of course you took
the bus today you could take a shuttle
over but you say you know what I'm gonna
walk because you know I've got digital
shoes and my health insurance provider
gives me discounts on my health
insurance if I walk more than a mile a
day and so of course you're gonna do
that and if you get your heart rate
above a certain level bonus points for
that so you do brisk walking over to
your other meeting and then it's time
you're going home you're gonna do some
shopping this is gonna be a Points
Festival oh my god it's so complicated
you can't figure it out so you go to
your app and you're like hey app these
are the things I want and it's like okay
here are the ones you should buy and of
course it knows just where they are on
the grocery store and so boom you get
like a whole bunch of points for the
shopping that your app told you to do so
you go home and your daughter's like hey
hey guess what I got my report card and
you're like whoa look at those grades
they're really good and so like you're
gonna get all these points you know from
the from the state for getting good
grades you know and that's gonna apply
towards your scholarship and as a parent
I'm gonna get the Barack Obama good
parenting bonus all right which I can
apply for tax relief which is really
useful and you're like wait a second did
you practice your piano today
and she says well yeah I practice my
piano you know well what score did you
get and she said oh well you know I got
I got eighty five thousand here like
eighty five thousand that's the best
you've ever done on that sonata that's a
new high score for you so boom points
for you from the Arts Council that apply
towards a scholarship for you so that's
very nice okay so that's done oh it's
time to the end of the day we're gonna
watch some TV and TV man that is just a
crazy crazy points decimal point some
point some point some points because
there's a camera on the TV now that came
in once you got that Microsoft Kinect
thing you mounted a camera on top of the
TV and it's watching you all the time
and people realize you can use this for
all kinds of things we can use it for
eye tracking and to tell when you're
actually looking at the ads and so
there's all these games about like
watching the ads follow the red ball you
know follow the logo right and so used
to be people we're skipping the ads but
that was they surpassed now everybody
wants to watch the ads because it's
points points points
and of course your remote has a screen
on it you know and of course it's
Facebook connected so you can chat with
your friends who were playing the same
games and you can see which friends are
watching which shows and have a
conversation and you play games together
and points and points and points
employing some points you know so that's
TV's me a very natural place to be full
of points and then finally okay fine I'm
gonna has kind of go to bed you get you
knew you know you got your Kindle 4.0 or
whatever it is and the cool thing about
the Kindle 4.0 is it has just like your
TV it has an eye tracker on it which is
nice because it can when you get stuck
on like what is this weird word what
does this mean it can sense
automatically that you're having trouble
reading the word it pops up a definition
that's really nice but also they can
tell what you've read and Amazon wants
to know that because if you're going to
review a book you're gonna get a heck of
a lot more points if you've read every
word of the book as opposed to if you
just gave it a skim and they'll know
because they want that information and
you finish reading your book and and
what do you know achievement unlocked
[ __ ] did I did I mention Microsoft
bought Amazon I mean that's probably
gonna happen anyway so achievement
unlocked you
had 500 novels this systems been
tracking you for like 20 years you've
unlocked 500 novels and you're like yes
500 novels that's an awesome achievement
but then you start to feel a little
stupid
you start to realize man my 500 novels
this dumb Star Trek novel and like it's
bad enough that I know that but like
that's memorialized because once we have
all these sensors and everything on us
watching us all the time everything that
we do all the time and we're gonna
remember it just like remember we use
you remember when used to delete email
and now we keep it all right we're gonna
keep all this data you don't know day to
day what your grandparents read what
books do they read where they go every
day but your grandchildren they're gonna
know they're gonna know everything you
read everything you did every day every
place you went because all the sensors
are there and recording it and you start
thinking maybe I better step up my
reading a little you know because man
this is gonna be my legacy and so it may
be that like this future with all these
disposable sensors maybe this is a gross
commercialization mess you know that you
don't want any part of but on the other
hand maybe it'll are just to kind of be
better than we were anyway so that was
the kind of ending of that dice talk
that I gave that um got people thinking
quite a bit and a lot of people people
had different reactions to this some
people were excited they thought this
was really cool other people thought no
this is not cool this is Orwellian and I
would have to say well no it's not
really technically it's Huxley because
you know you know 1984 was all about the
government using technology to control
people that's not what this is this is
more like brave new world where
technology controls us because it is so
pleasurable and that's that's a bit of a
different situation but still I
understand that people think it's creepy
other people said what this is
opening now right I talked about this
toothbrush thing and immediately after
the talk someone's like I have an oral-b
toothbrush already does this yeah like
it's it it times you it's got a three
minute thing and then it's a sad face if
you don't finish your three minutes and
you hit your three minutes and being
happy face and I'm like is it Wi-Fi
they're like no no it's not but I have a
Wi-Fi scale the guy says so there's a
scale out there that's Wi-Fi every time
you weigh yourself boom to a database so
you have a perpetual graph of your
weight effortlessly you can even
configure it to tweet your weight if you
would want that I don't know who would
want that but I figure it'll be about
five minutes before we get a Wi-Fi
toothbrush that'll be coming very soon
and what else then and and then all
these other things started coming out I
saw you've got the the shift of health
replay watch it's a regular watch more
or less that's kind of funky looking but
it's got motion sensor and when it can
when it senses after it senses an hour
of motion from like running or
exercising or something it spits out a
code and you type in the codes online
and you get like coupons for Starbucks
or or Barnes and Noble or things like
that you get things like green goose
which tracks you know how much you ride
your bike and they're working on doing
things it's like well how much are you
drinking water as opposed to drinking
soda in it you put it tilt sensor on the
bottle and it automatically uploads that
to the Internet and they have all kinds
of things like that
Tropicana juicy rewards I don't know if
people have seen this codes on your arm
juice and you type them in online and
you you get you get points and prizes
for drinking orange juice yeah mine
bloom is a real interesting one it's
meant to be kind of it's like a virtual
plant that represents your good habits
so you tell it oh I'd like to take
vitamins every day you know and I think
I should exercise and then like you you
you spend money to your little virtual
money to kind of make these commitments
and then when you meet the commitments
you get paid back in your little tree it
like grows my trees all sad and dead but
anyway
and then there's epic win if you want to
check out epic win app calm or just get
check out the epic win app on I think
it's on the other iPhone I think it's
coming to the Droid
it basically takes your to-do-list and
turns it into a role-playing game and so
you get experience points and level you
know and you'll level up every time you
complete these things and it turns into
this big adventure and there's so many
uh NBC started this Fannett thing it's
like hey you like our shows well earn
points so you watch a trailer for a show
we'll give you points for that you tweet
about a show and they'll give you points
for that and you can use these points
you cash them in and buy t-shirts for
NBC sprays advertise yourself and we'll
give you free advertisements so you can
advertise to other people and and then
freaking honey nut cheerios came up with
an augmented reality application you
hold the box up in front of the in front
of your webcam and you use it to like
steer through this like virtual
environment so cereal boxes are like
part of the game pocalypse ahead of
schedule
I didn't did not expect that see that
coming so one question is what the hell
right I mean so we have here we have
games or creeping into reality realities
creeping into games and all of life it
starts to become a game one question
would be why why would this happen why
in the world would this happen well the
fundamental reason is games are awesome
Riot Games are really cool they're fun
and they're interesting and we love
games right so we want things to be
awesome so of course games are gonna
come through and creep into things but
let's be more specific about this people
talk about how things are becoming
game-like let's break it down some of
the things we like about games there's a
lot to like in games games have a lot of
cool stuff some of the things game
provide they provide clear feedback when
you're at work it's like how am i doing
at work you know it's hard to know you
know is why does my boss think and you
get these vague senses in a game it's
like did you beat level three no I
totally beat level three it's not
ambiguous right boss monster is dead
right and now I'm on level four
though I got a batch look I mean it's
it's very very clear the feedback you
get
you get this sense of progress about
getting better and better and better and
it's very clear and you love it we love
those little progress bars we love them
it's really hard not to fill in that
progress bar even though you don't want
to you know mmm no farmville I don't
want to post oh I'll get a hundred
percent on my progress bar yes yes I
finished a progress bar okay games give
you the possibility of success we
attempt a lot of things in life is it
good is it gonna work is it even
possible I don't know you know but in
games if there's a game yeah it can be
won yeah almost always right you know
that games give you mental exercise they
give you physical exercise we like that
those are important part of games games
let you satisfy your curiosity that's a
big part of games it's one of the things
that you you come in you're like wow I
can I solve this how am I gonna do it
and and you get to do that which is
which is pleasing and you get a chance
to solve a problem and we like solving
problems we find it very rewarding
particularly when there are problems
that we know are potentially solvable
not just weird head cracking problems
and they're problems that when they're
solved in and it's very clear that you
have solved the problem and it is 100%
and fully solved we like that a lot and
games give you a feeling of freedom and
this is maybe one of the most defining
things about games that's how they're
not work work you have to do right if
there's a game and I make you play it
it's not fun anymore it doesn't feel
like a game it's a game that you entered
two games willfully you do it because
you want to and people who are like and
and this has been very thought-provoking
for me because so much of what we're
getting into is about this and there's
an excellent book it's actually a book
from the 80s finite and infinite games
and it's actually a philosophy book the
subtitle is a vision of life as play and
possibility and it talks about how there
are two ways to approach everything one
is as a finite game a thing that can be
won or lost and another is an infinite
game a thing that you enter into with a
sense of curiosity in a sense of
playfulness and this is a very
interesting philosophical approach
partly I find it fascinating because it
it presumes that all of life is just a
series of games and then secondly it
goes right toe to toe with the sense of
what exactly is freedom and how does it
relate to us anyway you might want to
check that out so uh one of the things
that you have to do if you're going to
think about this seriously I mean you're
trying to predict the future and a lot
of people are I've given up on
predicting the future and this audience
is certainly very familiar with the
concept of the singularity and I often
find that people mean very different
things when they talk about the
singularity some people talk about it as
some artificial intelligence moment or
some computing moments I don't think
that's what's important the nature of
the singularity the singularity in my
mind is very much the moment when
technologies advance so far that we are
unable to predict what the world will be
like five seconds from now right a
thousand years ago you could make a
pretty good prediction about what things
would be like one year later or five
years later or even ten or twenty years
later for us to predict twenty years in
the future now whoa that seems really
hard even two years and the number is
creeping in and eventually the idea of
the singularity is that it'll be five
seconds and you won't even be able to
guess what what's going on and with this
happening right because of this this
this threshold the prediction threshold
is creeping in it's made a lot of people
give up on prediction
they've become future blind they're like
I can't even think about it something's
gonna happen I don't know I'll put my
money here derp right and that's that's
that's ridiculous because if you put
some energy into it you can make some
predictions about the future right you
can look into your crystal ball and you
can figure it out but it takes practice
and the ironic part is if you practice
it the singularity is actually helping
you because be
for you to predict okay what's gonna be
up with mobile applications two years in
the future and to really put your mind
on it and focus well guess what in two
years you're gonna have some good
feedback about right or wrong and then
you can use that and say oh I did a bad
job predicting that time maybe I'll do
better if you practice predicting you
will get better and you're gonna get
feedback fast but if your future blind
and you don't bother you're gonna
continue to suck at predicting the
future so with that in mind I here are
some of my attempts to kind of predict
some of the things that are coming down
the road as we move towards the game
pocalypse some of them will be right so
I'm going to be wrong but hopefully
they'll be meaningfully
thought-provoking
so there's us and there's the game
pocalypse up there and we're gonna get
there do we want to get there well maybe
you do maybe you don't but it's coming
so we might as well figure it out
is it a straight line no it's kind of a
windy path to get there and there's a
lot of things on the way there's
different things on the way so some of
the things we're gonna see we're gonna
see a lot of different sort of cultural
forces that are at work we're gonna see
a heck of a lot of technologies on the
way that are gonna make a difference for
us and we're going to see some
implications towards the nature of
design that come out of all this so when
you add it all up oh my god there's a
lot of stuff on this windy path and
that's fine we can deal with a lot of
stuff so here we go we'll go on our path
and we'll start with the idea of nooks
and crannies and this has become very
important for games so as we as games
are creeping everywhere people always
say Oh what's where game's going I'm
like they're going everywhere and there
are a lot of forces at work doing this
some of them are technology some of them
in technological similar cultural some
of them are financial but there's
pressures for games to go everywhere so
if you're gonna make games you need to
look in the places they haven't gone yet
and so there are all these weird nooks
and crannies that we can look in to
figure out where games are gonna go one
of them is who's playing games used to
be it's like okay yeah males 15 to 25
that's our target damn
graphic one of the things that's
happened recently is no everyone is
playing games male female young old
their games for everybody but what nooks
and crannies can you go into that you
haven't gotten into yet have you figured
out how to make a game for fishermen
have you figured out how to make a game
for pogo-stick enthusiasts I mean
there's all these nooks and crannies of
the human race they can go to some of
them are geographical right there's a
lot of games for Americans games in Asia
are a little different not too many
people make games for Africa because
they don't have so much money there but
like who's making games for the Middle
East
cuz I'll tell you what those guys have a
lot of freaking money right I bet they'd
love it if someone would make them some
great games but it's not happening but
someone's gonna write so there's nooks
and crannies that way but one of the
most important nooks and crannies is
when you look at how you spend your day
this is going to be the battlefield of
the 21st century as the world tries to
compete for your attention in everything
that you do right already you know
leisure time that's well understood in
terms of where games are but the big
explosion of Facebook gaming that's
because you can play Facebook games at
work and no one will know right suddenly
boom there's this huge chunk of time you
can like spend playing games that you
weren't before look at the size of that
compared to socializing right and then
there's all these other things can I
have games that are part of TV oh my god
that's gonna be huge for games household
activities can the Swiffer is almost a
game can I get points for doing the
Swiffer right grooming I talked about
toothbrushes can connect doing my hair
be that REM sleep we talked about that
and well anyway so this is like one way
to think about carving things up oh can
I have a game you know I already play
games with my dog where I like throw him
a stick and he brings it back can there
be points and stuff is there a digital
version you get a million points because
you're so cute
okay moving on alright so this nook and
cranny principle we're gonna see this
coming up a lot and one thing related to
this is the idea of microtransactions it
used to be with games you plunked down
your money you get a big fat game and
that was how it worked now we have the
ability to spend 50 cents here or $1
there and it's changed the way games
work because you can start playing for
free and then in the game when you want
something because we want things in the
middle of a game they can say ah that
thing's 50 Cent's right and that changes
what we can do it lets us put games in
places they weren't before and people
sometimes ask well wait a minute do
people really want these
microtransactions I'm not sure I really
believe in this and I'm like are you a
freaking idiot have you seen the App
Store people are happy to spend 99 cents
on some dumb thing right you know in in
huge millions and millions of dollars
and we've seen this have a huge impact
on the game industry look at this chart
of handheld revenue right 2008 it was
Nintendo DS was a clear winner PSP we're
doing okay iPhone yeah we got a little
bit of game software oh by 2009 PSP is
like falling in half
iPhone is taking this huge chunk right
and Nintendo still hanging in there but
I think they're like hey wait a minute
how can we get some of that action
and now what about like on the game
consoles why don't we see this on the
game consoles and the reason is these
guys are freaking scared to death of
microtransactions they're like no no no
we want our fifty bucks we you spend 50
bucks on a game you don't spend a
quarter I don't want that none of them
wants to be the one that really opens
the door for like free games and
suddenly games got really cheap but
somebody's gonna do it I bet it's gonna
be some fourth console that comes in and
does that and these guys are all gonna
feel like they have to catch up we'll
find out and here's one other thing if
you take social networking and you
combine that with microtransactions oh
my god that's like peanut butter and
chocolate
right cuz you're playing for free and
you and your friends are hanging out and
then suddenly social pressure to spend
fifty cents oh alright alright but
social pressure is so much stronger than
other kinds of pressure and and it works
really really well with micro
transactions so yeah now an interesting
thing to note the companies that are
succeeding with micro transactions these
are not the companies that succeeded
traditionally in the game space none of
the big game companies are really
succeeding here it's always it's these
new guys Zynga and play fish and play
them did you hear Disney bought played
them for five hundred million dollars
today and then you got big point and
you're up oh my goodness and I oh this
was an example I decided before this
really shook up the game industry a
little formula EA - fifteen hundred
full-time staff plus play fish - three
hundred million dollars which is what
they bought for equals you know what in
the world is going on clearly the game
industry is changing and turning upside
down these two things happen in the same
day you 1500 people you're laid off okay
ply fish come on and here's your three
hundred million dollars everyone's like
wait why wait even if you divide that it
doesn't in any way all right moving on
now this all relates to I know many
people are familiar with this book in
this audience the claim clay Christensen
is the innovators dilemma oh it's such
it it's so much describes the situation
this book is all about why big companies
in Denver see it coming right huh which
is crazy you think big companies they're
smart that's how they got big of course
they're going to see the future coming
no they don't
little guys grow up and the reason is
this difficult to comprehend graph
so this graph is like product
performance how awesome your product is
right and this is overtime all right so
so here all products they get better
over time we know that they're gonna get
better because you're gonna keep
advancing well that's that's fine that's
great here's a product getting better
slowly and here's one getting better
fast
well they point out these important
lines and these are two important lines
this one at the top is all about yeah I
don't need anything better than this
there's a certain amount of gigahertz
where you're like no seriously my web
surfing is fine you know a hundred
million gigahertz it's not no I just
seriously I'm just watching videos and
stuff man I don't know I'll to keep my
old one alright and and there's that
line and then the other line is this
important one down here this is the line
if it's below this you're like no that
thing's garbage I can't use it within
the second it's above it you're like oh
yeah that's good enough that's fine I
can use that and what happens to the big
companies they get something that's up
here people like it they're using it and
they say customers what should we do and
the customers are like make you better
okay all right we make it better what
about now make it better all right we'll
make it better
hey hey customers I'm gonna take a pause
at this moment and ask you what you
think of this alternate technology and
they say boo socks not good enough for
me take yours and make it better all
right
I'm making it better what do you think
of it now they're like um I don't really
need it to be this good and you'll have
to excuse me because I need to go buy
this because it's like way cheaper and
it does everything I need I'm like I
just asked you about that and they're
like yeah but that was before it was
quite good enough right and this is what
happens every every every time and if
you're predicting the future this is a
very useful tool for you all right
moving on lalla next step new sensors oh
my gosh this is how games are gonna get
everywhere because we're gonna sense
things because games have to sense
things because otherwise how do they
know what's going on and every time some
new sensor shows up there's a new way to
make a game about it right and there's
so many kinds of scent
coming it was so exciting with the you
know when people have the iPhone oh it's
tilty and a million games came out all
about tilting and suddenly tilting was
fine whoo I can touch it and that's fun
every time a new sensor shows up you can
you can do something and so like we've
seen you know the Wii Fit it's like wow
you can do these kind of exercise things
and that's cool right and and of course
we had the Wii was a big revolution and
now we're gonna have the Microsoft
Kinect which has a camera up there you
can use your whole body right as a
controller and that's coming out this
Christmas and that's cool and then
you've got the PlayStation Move which is
a similar sort of thing where it can
sense motion except it's more detailed
so everybody's doing these things that
are all about this full sensing and know
we're still figuring out how you're
gonna use it but we've got those but but
it's a good thing to pause and think for
a second because everyone just assumes
oh I'll be able to move my whole body
and therefore that's more realistic and
so it's better and that's why it's
better right because you're moving a
whole body it's more realistic and if
you ask Nintendo they say no no no
that's not why Nintendo talks about the
problem of too many buttons Nintendo's
goal in creating the Wii mote was not
because motion was cool Nintendo was
said their problem was they looked at it
was not enough people are playing games
and they went to people who didn't play
games and they said you used to play
games you know how come you stopped and
people would say oh well the controller
it used to be simple it had a couple
buttons then they got all complicated
they got all these buttons it's way too
many buttons I can't deal with so many
buttons they would say a Nintendo said
okay well maybe that is the problem too
many buttons but they thought about it
and they said wait a minute you say it's
too many buttons but you've got one of
these it's got way more buttons and in
fact I've been to your house you've got
three of them on the couch that's a lot
of freaking buttons that's way more
buttons than we've got on this thing and
they realized oh it's not the number of
buttons it's a something in Tendo calls
simultaneous ambidextrous control in
other words having to use both hands at
once to
do different things is what the these
modern controllers demands of the player
and that is cognitively difficult for
people and is not a function of number
of buttons the and you notice these
remotes
none of them they demand you to use two
hands at once for two different things
they don't ask that
and so Nintendo said well if we made a
game controller that was one-handed how
could we do it because you need to do a
lot of things and they said oh what if
we use we've been fooling around with
motion control what if we used motion
control so we didn't need so many
buttons and that was why they made the
the Wemo because that's that's how it
feels to to a player who's not used to
it
all right and so they made the Wiimote
which is ah it's just so simple right it
even has fewer buttons in there and and
so yeah that's very nice anyway so
sensors are going everywhere and they're
gonna get we're gonna be able to sense
all kinds of things you've got Nike+ has
sensors in your shoes we're gonna be
able to sense temperature we get
Foursquare sensing where you are out in
the world sensors sensors sensors
sensors we're gonna see more of them and
they're gonna be cheap and they're gonna
be disposable and they're gonna be on
everything and that's gonna let us play
all kinds of games someone after the
talk said oh yeah I wanted to tell you
about I work for this company and we
make pills that have sensors in them
they're they're powered by your gastric
juices and it can sense like temperature
in your body and it sends out like a
little radio signal boom - a little
band-aid that you've put on and the
band-aid receives like a temperature
information over time in your body
and I'm like while you're talking to me
what why are you telling me well we're
thinking of making a game out of it on
my own great that sounds like a great
game
and some people say oh they joke about
implants and like well we might get
implants when they've been implants are
a pain so if implants are coming
meaningful implants I think they're
gonna start in the tooth because teeth
are cool they're like bones outside your
skin anyway that's just a note about
teeth and implants all right moving on
so there's a lot of new sensors but you
got to have more than sensors you need
screens right we're gonna have all these
new screens that are gonna show up we're
already seeing screens show up in our
lives first we saw hay screens in your
pocket and now everyone carries a little
screen around they all have a screen all
the time and people are like good I
don't need any more screens but no of
course not
you're gonna have more and more and more
screens because screens are getting
cheaper and we like because technology
always diverges and so we're gonna have
more and more screens
Sybil's safety oh are you in the
audience whereas if do you know alright
so safety oh these guys are like making
these little cubes that have screens on
them that can sense the presence of each
other and so you can do interactive
games and activities on the tabletop
like it's kind of like a cross between
board game and video game and app and
it's it's a new way of kind of
interacting and it all has to do with
having multiple screens that you can
move around a place relative to each
other and so we're gonna have this kind
of coffee table board game space is
gonna start to have a lot of screens in
it and now I've made a joke at back in
February and it was real funny in
February right after the the iPad came
out I was talking about technologies and
how they they diverge and and I was
saying how the the iPhone like
technologies always diverge but the
iPhone is weird because it has a
convergence of technologies kind of like
a Swiss Army knife does and that this is
only possible because the only place
technologies don't diverge is in your
pocket it's the pocket exception to the
law of divergence and then so yeah sure
a Swiss Army knife right it makes total
sense in your pocket but if I gave you
one for your kitchen you'd say that's
really stupid because like you can only
do one thing at a time and it's
difficult to clean you say this is
awkward and ridicul
and and that's why everyone hates the
iPad right now at the time that got a
roaring laugh back in February but then
a couple months later I told the same
joke and people like but now I kind of
like that pattern so iPads actually kind
of cool and the reason for this is for
the hype curve from the Gartner group
for people who know about this all
technologies follow this same curve they
start with a basic technology trigger at
the bottom and like you this cool thing
just got invented now this is a graph of
visibility over time right and so this
thing got invented and then everybody
starts talking about it no one has seen
it yet all right everyone's talking
about oh it's so awesome you know
they're talking about it so so amazing I
can't wait it's gonna change my life
right and they're waiting outside the
store in order to buy the thing and this
is a point called the peak of inflated
expectations and then the thing comes
out and everyone sees for what it really
is and they all say boo we hate it and
we go deep into the trough of
disillusionment and it's boo this thing
is horrible and we hate it and it sucks
but then eventually people figure out oh
I see what this is for and then over
time they figure out okay it's not
doesn't change everything but it's good
for some things and that's really nice
and so at the time like I told that joke
it was like right here right paper like
oh man I thought the iPad was gonna
change everything
but then when there later people are
like oh actually the seconds of web
surfing on the couch just kind of it's
kind of nice I kind of figured it out
and and Saturday Night Live they had it
right when the iPad came out they made a
great joke about it they said it was hey
the iPad came out this weekend's 300,000
people bought it a $500 each paid for
for this which brings in a new era of
people buying things to find out what
they are
right which is totally true cuz you see
people the iPad they're like should I
bring it to work I guess
maybe I don't know what's it for right
yeah and they they gradually gradually
figure it out and it turns out what the
iPads freaking awesome for is like
computing on the couch computing on the
couch always sucked before trying to do
your laptop kind of sucks or you use the
phone but it's so small it's actually
really nice for the couch it's great it
feels a little nook and cranny in my
life that I didn't know I needed right
it's like oh this is pretty great I
don't know if I want to carry it
everywhere all the time I feel weird at
a meeting typing on that thing but but
on the couch I mean that's pretty great
so what have we learned from this put
jokes here we we've learned that
certainly well I think the deeper thing
is that to figure out the nooks and
crannies that the plateau of
productivity is all about we have to
figure out where these were these go
okay oh oh and I love this this was
announced like two days ago company in
India has announced they're going to
make a tablet computer 35 bucks it's
coming out in 2012
I think they've announced 35 bucks and
my favorite part about it is this
picture of the guy good hey check it out
35 bucks you'll combine an iPad or you
could buy 15 of these okay and anyway it
seems sort of silly but it certainly
points to the fact that screens are
gonna get cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and you're gonna be able to put
them in all kinds of weird places that
you didn't think of before oh and
there's a side note on this the person
who figures out how to combine digital
pornography with a waterproof shampoo
bottle is going to be very rich that
person will make a lot of money
remember this day for itn't sham porn
alright okay alright moving on let's
move out of that definitely all right so
let's move to the next stop the next
horrifying stop there are fantasy
experiences we have to go involve
screens at all and so for example our
dreams it's really interesting to think
about dreams cuz dreams are like I mean
you can't get any more immersive than
that I like to think about who who
writes those they're good I'd like to
meet that guy cuz it's awesome some of
those things are exciting and terrifying
and and you know for plexi and I think
I'm like what what was what did he mean
by I donno um which guess the question
of can we control them and of course
there are people who have worked hard at
like you know there's the idea of lucid
dreams dreams where you have sort of
freedom to control and people have tried
to make devices that are all about
letting you know they sense when you've
entered REM sleep and then they send a
signal to you either by flashing lights
in your eyes or putting sound in your
ear like hey hey dummy you're having a
dream you should probably wake up but
not actually wake up but like be aware
of it and figure that out maybe I'm
crazy but I think this is a whole
untapped area that I think somebody is
gonna find a way in it's a kind of
manage our dream life so that we like it
more anyway because you know dreams are
awesome right moving on unfortunately
the people are probably gonna do it are
the advertising people because they have
the most reason to do it and let's talk
a little bit about the advertising
people they're having a tough time right
the print media is taking a beating and
that's where they got a lot of their
money and TV who watches ads on TV
everybody TiVo's and skips it and it
could be that that whole TV ad thing
collapses ads on the internet or mostly
a joke
and I think we know that so the ad
people are like ah what's going on so
games is one place they're like God
digging their fingernails in trying to
figure it out and initially they tried a
lot of sort of naive approaches that
don't make a lot of sense there's a lot
of times you can't just take any ad and
inject it into any game that just
doesn't really work very well so then
they tried making games based around
products right here's a whole bunch of
them you go online to play the sweet
tarts game or for some reason these are
always about sugar I don't know why that
is but that does seem to be the case so
they've done these these are okay I mean
you're you know there's some that but it
kind of only goes it only goes so far so
these guys are trying new things so
7-eleven cut a deal with Zynga so that
if you play farmville and you go to
Zynga and you buy a Slurpee there's like
a code on the cup and you get like farm
cash in farmville for every Slurpee you
buy and I think this is just the
beginning because these virtual
economies in these games are powerful we
want to make more of our virtual money
we want more World of Warcraft gold and
we want more farm cash and the and the
the advertisers are waking up and like
oh we can we can give you that that's
easy that's just like a little data
thing and Boop we gave you imaginary
money we'll give you that if you'll pay
attention to our product sure um and
those advertising people man they're
sneaky you you've got to keep an eye on
them because man they get in there and
they figure it out so here's a graph of
commercial time from 1950 to 2010 it
went from 13% of television time it's
now 36% did anyone notice right well
right because you notice how they snuck
it in they took 50 years to frickin
sneak in it but they did they creep it
up they creep it up remember when they
added the logo in the corner Boop so
that every second you're watching
television they're burning
Bran's into your brain and nobody liked
it but we didn't stop it we couldn't
make it not happen or what if I told you
that like a major corporation was gonna
scan every email you received and every
email you sent and build a personalized
digital profile of what it thought you
were interested in and then every time
you tried to read the email it would pop
up distractions custom crafted to pull
your eyes away from your email and to
distract you
it sounds horrifying and it's called
Gmail right and we're all like yeah
that's cool I like Gmail I think that's
pretty great you know it's all free and
stuff and right hmm so advertising is
insidious or like men you know I grew up
you know in New Jersey and you know we
go to Shea Stadium
yes screw Shea Stadium now it's City
Bank Stadium you know hooray for San
Francisco you took back Candlestick Park
it's not Monster Park anymore so good
job at least for the next five minutes
cuz it's gonna be Zynga Park I'm sharing
like 20 minutes or everybody enjoy
Candlestick Park for the brief moment
that it lasts okay anyway um so Austin's
game designers we're gonna have new
weird [ __ ] to deal with that we weren't
used to it used to be we just made a
game and try to make it awesome and now
we're gonna have all these weird ethical
decisions to make that that we didn't
have to make before the print media
people have had to do this somebody at
Wired magazine had to say yeah Camel
cigarettes what our magazine convinced
more people to buy and smoke Camel
cigarettes yeah and then I had to make a
sales pitch to camel yeah we think so we
think here's why here the people who
read wire are likely to be influenced by
these ads blah blah blah and they had to
do that and decide that they felt good
about doing that I had games people we
don't normally to do that oh yeah we're
gonna have to do it and it's gonna be
way worse anyway alright so advergaming
is going to be a big piece of
and some of that's gonna be pretty scary
all right so a cultural trend Beauty
let's talk about Beauty one of the
things is wonderful about the 21st
century everything is getting so freakin
beautiful oh my gosh um hey just
everywhere you turn I mean you go to the
grocery store and they used to be
I remember 30 years ago you buy a
toothbrush they came in one shape and
three colors and that was it now it's
like a tropical fish aquarium right
there are all sizes and colors and
shapes and textures and it's just it's
amazing right things are beautiful
remember when telephones were ugly and
now it's like oh my telephone is so
beautiful right and we hold it up as a
standard this telephone is a standard of
beauty and interface and like a
telephone really but that's just how it
is and we certainly see it in the video
game world or video games are getting
more and more beautiful
all the time and so this this is this is
like a big a big trend in even
architecture I just was in the UK I gave
a talk in this building I was at the
game horizon conference this is a 21st
century building it's freaking gorgeous
you can't help but like look at this
building and mean we wouldn't have built
that in the 20th century in the 20th
century you built all this crap down
here but right right the 20th centi
first century we built stuff like that
because we just want things that are
beautiful and so talked about how does
this beauty in a matter well oh oh and
everyone should read this book have
people read this book to rational
optimist this is like become one of my
favorite books ever the premise of the
book is yeah you know how everyone's
always complaining about the frickin end
of the world everything's so bad I mean
it's getting worse and worse this book
says no no it's not look at all the
numbers everything is getting better
hunger is getting better crime is
getting better pollution is getting
better better better better better
everything is getting so much better and
in the end impacts it all up and it's
like oh man
this 21st century is gonna be awesome
you know if you look at these numbers
and even if it's not it's gonna at least
be beautiful right it's gonna be pretty
so this is definitely a trend that we're
seeing people want more more beauty in
their lives and a question
comes with television I'm gonna take a
little side note here to talk about 3d
TV because everyone's like yeah 3d TV we
went for regular to HD now we're gonna
go to 3d right and it's gonna be amazing
and everyone's gonna buy it and I'm just
just just putting out there I don't know
if I believe that that that is the case
and III I've worked with 3d a lot right
I did all these theme park things I made
this Toy Story Mania is glorious 3d and
its really great and super fun in a
theme park but in your house everyday 3d
I will point out that stereoscopy was
invented in 18-49 about the same time as
photography it's not technically
difficult to do if you wanted every
picture that you ever took could be in
3d but you don't do that cuz you don't
freaking care if you thought 3d was so
awesome all your snapshots to be in 3d
but no you don't think it's that awesome
you think it's kind of a novelty
reserved for certain places so if we
don't want it for our photography I
don't know if we want it with all our
television and so oh and I love this
none of people realized Alfred Hitchcock
made a 3d movie he made dial M for
murder in 3d and when he saw how it came
out he was so disappointed with his
ability to use 3d to achieve meaningful
dramatic effect he wouldn't release it
in 3d there were prints eventually
released but the premiere was not in 3d
and I'm like man if Alfred Hitchcock
can't pull it off what what the hope to
the rest of us have so I posit that I
think 3d TV is probably more like 5.1
stereo surround sound then it is HD TV
rich nerds will have it and everyone
else will go to their house now in them
okay moving on from TV so another trend
is a trend of customization we see this
all over the video game world right it's
a big change in video games everybody
used to be you know burnt there's Mario
and you got Mario now you've you
customize the heck out of your
characters people expect it but it's not
just in videogames people are
customizing everything right because
they can write and this isn't some
made-up thing this is real you can go do
this now right you could be eating your
face right now right and and we're seen
everywhere seeing in board games right
there's this big line of Lego board
games that's come out look at me know if
your board game nerds out there I mean
reiner knizia
you know he's the designer this thing
he's he's a for reals game designer and
you know there's there's a whole bunch
of these things and it's cool you build
the board and you build it different
every time like everything's becoming
customizable and this is an important
trend and one of the ways we're
breathing to see it being important is
this iron face tracking in the next 10
20 years is going to be very very
influential right now we see it when you
put a camera on the camera drill
sometimes you use a camera sometimes if
you got a fancy camera draws squares
over your kids faces and you're like
what the hell is this
right and presumably it's doing
something important but I don't know it
is just scares me when I see it because
I'm like I don't know what you're doing
camera it's kind of scary but our
ability to track and sense faces one of
the ways it's going to be used is with
massively multiplayer gaming to be able
to track your facial expression map it
right on to an avatar this is going to
go a long way this is going to allow you
not just to customize the look but as
you speak and express your gonna
actually be able to put your own
expression and personality into
characters in ways we haven't seen
before and that's that's gonna be that's
gonna be very important and you know
while we're talking about facial
tracking faces are like really easy to
tell apart that's partly why our faces
differ so much and we have all this
Hardware in our heads so we can tell
each other apart other
we'd be really confused about who was
who right that's just part of being
human well people have been starting to
develop these technologies like
recognizer right hold up your iPhone and
it's like oh I know who that is and Boop
it pops up their Twitter and all this
crap right around them and you can see
the look on her face she's like would
you put that crap down and talk to me
you know and and they picked a name
recognizer that's not like creepy at all
it has no connotations of being creepy
anyway but you know think of how you've
put public photos of yourself online if
you've ever done that very soon people
will be harvesting those to make a giant
database of who's who so you can play
games with that right imagine a game
where it's like you got to take pictures
you get points every time you find
someone you never seen before with your
phone ding ding ding ding ding anyway
but probably I don't think it'll be so
much games I think I'll be more
practical applications connect that to
social networking and you get stuff like
this you know like oh yeah yeah that's
who that oh you know it's my brother and
now you have a conversation starter with
people which is sort of cool and useful
and so you start think about all the
other data that's out there and how
you'd probably be able to walk down the
street since we know the addresses and
we can look stuff up with the car
license plates and it's like yeah here's
who lives in that house and here's how
old they are and here's which car
belongs to what house and it starts to
be terrifying and it's like wait a
minute wait a minute who gave up this
information we all gave it up because we
didn't think anyone could see it we
thought obscurity would keep us safe and
it wouldn't it's it's a lot kind of like
Adam and Eve and who like ate the Apple
and they're like huh we're naked what
the hell right we're all naked I'm just
telling you right now and pretty soon
we're gonna eat the Apple and realize oh
oh what we can do about this but that's
not my problem to solve
while we're talking about that why stop
with just facial recognition we now have
these kind of mind sensors you know
brain sensors it contains sense brain
activity and different kinds of brain
activity and that's sort of cool people
are making games we levitate a ping-pong
ball whatever that's kind of cool
but think about the asset you know how
education could change you know if you
could suddenly you know teachers out
there monitoring like what's going on
you know with with different kids and
that's kind of horrifying to think about
but on the other side it could be very
very positive because imagine a school
where they're like we don't care what
you're working on as long as you're
thinking hard customize the holy hell
out of your education and as long as
you're thinking hard we're happy is that
good or bad or I don't know anyway
alright moving on this leads me to the
next topic something I often refer to as
a curiosity gap that the Internet has
brought us and it's this way it used to
be if you were curious about something
it could be freaking hard to get the
information about it
you know there's certain topics you had
to go to library libraries close you get
there they don't have the right books
you had to work hard to get information
a kid today who wants to find out about
I don't know well you know what does
piezoelectric mean boom there's the
information right there kid wants to
make a robot boom here's a million plans
for robots here's how you do it here's
how to instructions here's a video of a
guy who did it and you just have an
infinite amount of information and what
this means is curious people have an
insane advantage because they can learn
anything they want incredibly fast
people who are not curious are going to
be left behind creating this curiosity
gap between the curious and the inkers
and what this implies is that the most
important thing that we can do for our
children is not to give them facts or
figures or techniques but to make them
curious but the problem is we don't know
very much about curiosity at all we know
very little about it and we certainly
don't know whether it's possible to
instill it are you born with it
did your parents give it to you can it
be taught who took a class that made
them more curious we don't know and it
may be the most important thing I hope
we figure it out because I really do
believe if we can figure this out it's
going to lead to a significant
revolution in education where education
will go from being standardized to
customized because customized education
is better because who wins out in the
world the guy with the standardized
education or the person who got so
excited about one topic that they got
better at it than anyone in the world
that's the person who wins and that's
exactly what our education system does
not do anyway moving on oh my goodness
thank you don't don't clap I'm not done
baby oh yeah we got half a map to go
here all right
so I mentioned authenticity before and
this is a really important trend people
do want things that are more real and to
connect with things that feel more real
to them and this is big part of the rise
of social networking so let me explain
social networking it's a fancy term that
means Facebook all right so that's wait
wait wait I'm gonna and this is serious
this is serious try not to laugh raise
your hand if you're not on Facebook oh
man all right good for you I give you a
week right all right and things on
Facebook people speak of things going
viral
remember when viral was bad right now
viral is awesome it's really good and
the reason is because when people talk
about things going viral they usually
mean it in a good way right things go
viral like for four reasons they're
funny they're very helpful they're
unique or they're amazing or spectacular
or they're controversial these are all
reasons that things go viral and those
are all kind of good meaningful reasons
for a thing to go viral but with all
this talk of viral people often forget
there are bad viruses right bad viruses
that like make you sick and unhappy and
not just in the real world no like you
know
in the virtual world as well you know
and this has been one of the things a
lot of these businesses in the in this
universe have been all about spamming
the holy hell out of you and your
friends and that works really well for a
virus it you know it kind of spreads
everywhere but if it's a virus that
makes you sick and you don't like it and
you roll your eyes when that little pop
up comes well guess what's going to kick
in the immune system right and there are
two immune systems working in Facebook
right now one of them is the the people
who use Facebook at first it's like oh
someone sent me a cow oh I guess that's
kind of cool but very quickly you're
like no no hide hide hide hide hide
application hide use or hide Facebook
right and the second one is Facebook
itself they started to change their
rules because they see people are
disgusted with it and so they start
changing their rules no can't stand this
kind of spam anymore and so double
immune systems are kicking in for things
that are the unhealthy kind of viral but
there is the good kind of viral right so
if you're gonna make things that are
viral make them the good kind of viral
not the bad kind
because the immune system is gonna kick
your butt alright so moving on um
another aspect of authenticity is the
idea of transmedia world's people want
their fantasy it's weird to say this
people want their fantasy worlds to feel
real right
okay that's strange but it's true and
one of the aspects of these transmedia
worlds is that they have many many
points of entry right that you can get
to them from you can get to them from
books and you can get them from TV and
from from different kinds of games and
maybe them from a toy or that there are
many ways to get there and it's the
people who are figuring out the rules
not so much the rules for a game or a
book but like what are the rules of a
world that make it seem real and solid
because some worlds are really
succeeding this way and some kind of
aren't quite as well it's interesting to
compare say Lord of the Rings which is a
big transmedia win and Narnia which
somehow isn't holding up there and
people are just starting to understand
this and in terms of enduring worlds
that going to creep into every aspect
of your life you've got to understand
the transmedia because it's a huge trend
in in gaming right now
and this actually relates in an
interesting way to what's going on in
the music industry used to be a musician
cut a deal with a record label and it
was all about making records and that
was what they did and they might deal
with someone else to get their concerts
now they do these new things they call
360 deals where the record labels like
no no we'll handle everything for you
the music and the concert and your
magazine stuff and your merchandise and
your deal with the you know with the
video game companies and your TV
appearances and it's like all one deal
and this happened because you know the
foolish music industry relied entirely
on like you know they distributed things
on discs and they sold them that way and
you know the game industry would never
be so dull missed did you oh crap
right that's exactly what they're doing
and piracy is starting to sneak up on
them and it's going to be more and more
of a problem but once you have
transmedia world's where it's not just
the game that matters but having it be
in many parts of your life then they
have a property that's worth more
okay so you got transmedia worlds and
here's another technology that ties in
with authenticity um
speech recognition this has been super
slow I remember when I was a kid it's
like oh 10 years away you're gonna have
speech recognition you're awesome and
ten years later like where is it they're
like oh don't worry it's just ten years
away and I asked it was I was talking to
Kevin Kelly today we're talking about
speech recognition he says well I
figured that'd be here in ten years I'm
like yeah sure I guess I don't know but
it is creeping up you know we have it
you can like make a phone call
mostly and that kind of works so Chris
Swain at USC makes this awesome analogy
about video games and their importance
in the 21st century
he says video games right now are like
silent films were at the beginning of
the 20th century people didn't take
silent film seriously they're cute
they're kind of funny you know there
were a bunch of nerds who thought they
were awesome and amazing this little
niche community but the community at
large add that's not real entertainment
there was a technological breakthrough
boom films could talk and all of a
sudden everything changed and films
became the
dominant medium of the 21st century they
became the literature of the 20th
century I mean rather and they took over
they they displaced print as the medium
of the time well Chris Wayne suggests
the videogames are going through
something similar but of course they can
talk but what they can't do is they
can't listen and that once they can
listen to us understand our words and
understand the meaning behind our words
and react meaningfully to us well when
that can happen something changes we are
now in a new medium can you imagine a
medium where like you can't like get
through you can't get through the
adventure unless you like persuade the
character that like you know you know no
I'm sincere when I'm telling you this no
I you know I'm I know I'm gonna change
how do you if you actually had to bring
real emotion into the experience when
you interact with the characters that's
gonna that's a level of medium that we
haven't had before and it's interesting
to think about games because games
subsume all other media I can put a book
in a game or a movie in a game or a song
in a game I don't put anything in a game
games live outside everything ultimately
they will subsume every technology that
they they touch and the other cool thing
about speech is it lets me find new
nooks and crannies you know I can play
video games a lot I cannot play them in
the car and I'll tell you I have tried
all right it's not a good idea but
imagine if I'm driving and like I don't
need a screen it's like uh-oh there's
two orcs coming at you I'm like oh get
my sword out and attack those orcs right
and I could just talk you know with this
thing and it's like no you know and I
just have a conversation cuz I can talk
to a person in the car that's fine if I
could talk to my game system have it be
a game that'd be freaking awesome anyway
every new sensor every new technology
gives you a new nook and cranny
geo-tracking
alright let's talk about geo-tracking so
we see this a lot right you can track
where you are GPS and people are talking
about Foursquare and everything and I
need to make a little aside about this I
don't know if people have seen this
movie frequently asked questions about
time travel it's really awesome and I'm
gonna
just a short clip of something that I
think is relevant and okay hopefully the
audio is good for this here han shot
first
more Firefly and serenity D hey didn't
we all agree to stop using the N word
didn't we I don't know it is the word
they use to keep us down you should use
the term imagined here yeah you are just
threatened you're threatened because you
don't understand our world Oh what's
this one this time they saw one Star
Trek film hates it it never looked back
really which one the first one with the
big gold robot and the little fat mayor
you mean Star Wars don't you do I are
they the same thing no no they're not he
knows what I know or even an Imagineer
better I'm glad you're happy anyway the
reason this is an awesome movie by the
way this is just this is an excellent
movie but I bring this up because it
sounds really funny you know he calls
himself he's like I'm not a nerd I'm an
Imagineer and it sounds like oh that's
just self you know just make himself
important but there's something here
right cuz nerd is like a phrase we used
to say anybody who's bookish or
antisocial what he's getting at is by
saying he's no no no we're Imagineers he
means oh we love to explore fantasy
worlds right is what he's sort of
getting at is that's what he's about
exploring these fantasy worlds and there
are people who are really really in to
fantasy worlds but then there's other
people who cannot comprehend that at all
it seems totally alien to them and we
don't talk about this psychological
dichotomy but it's very very real you
probably know people in your life who
are kind of leaning towards the
Imagineer side or leaning towards the
other side and it needs a name I call
them the mundanes
right you know mundane of pertaining to
worldly things real things and things
that are ordinary and that's kind there
is this battle there there are people
that are that are that way and this is
important because we're about to see
these guys go crunch like this because
right now the Imagineers own fantasy
gameplay right real gameplay in the real
world a la sports is owned by the
mundanes no sport has any element of
fantasy in it at all ever that's just
how it is and so there's a kind of
battle that's gonna go on once we start
to geo track people and we try and take
fantasy gaming elements and bring them
to the real world now what's funny is
these guys actually appear to have a lot
in common
they don't seem that different to me but
there is something fundamental keeping
them apart yeah so people say all Force
ground I say Foursquare is okay it's
kind of a little boring
I mean I'm either mayor of a thing or
I'm not and I you know I don't know I
think it's a novelty I'm not sure it's
gonna last and people say oh no no no no
you cuz it's just the beginning that's
just a platform people are gonna take
about Foursquare and like combine it
with world Warcraft is fantasy thing and
I'm like Foursquare Plus World of
Warcraft equals LARPing
and it's interesting to think about why
do we feel that way about LARPing
there's something fundamentally weird to
us about it and either will stay that
way and these two worlds will have to
stay apart somehow or maybe they'll find
ways to come together because fighting
is awesome right fighting is like
totally cool and fun and why I think it
were about five minutes away from
somebody saying hey this Wiimote is cool
in my living room but what if I made a
battery-powered one and putting in a
foam sword and it could measure how fast
I'm swinging it and it could measure
when I have contact with somebody and it
will automatically Boop transfer that
hit point damage to him based on how
much his armors already absorbed I mean
that would be sort of cool right that's
I think that's gonna happen and I think
people are gonna start doing it and the
question is will it be a sport like
fencing or will it be a fantasy oriented
thing or will it be both I have a
suspicion there's a real opportunity for
people to make theme parks out of this
that are more immersive it's funny to
kind of think back about the movie West
world well that's sort of what we're
talking about you can't go and have like
a week-long fantasy experience for the
most part right now but what if you
could what if there were actors and you
had these digital swords and stuff that
tracked your points and you really had
to dig real treasure with a real shovel
out of the ground that oh my gosh were
ambushed and there's horses and you
could do these things that could happen
and I think the biggest one of all will
be I call it world of world of warcraft
world or Wow WA for short I think anyway
so there's there's a prediction oh but
but of course the advertisers will catch
up with all this pretty soon and you'll
go and fight the cola wars or whatever
anyway all right we're getting near the
end here so another important trend
sharing sharing it's a huge thing in the
21st century everybody's sharing
everything they're sharing music and
they're sharing messages they're sharing
ideas what I heard about Wikipedia I'm
like no that's not gonna work that's
like the worst idea ever right if
everyone can edit the encyclopedia it
gets better
no it's gonna be the worst encyclopedia
ever no it's awesome this is possibly
the the crowning achievement of humanity
right so people love sharing they love
to share and and their games give them a
lot of opportunities to share and we've
seen this in some games LittleBigPlanet
you get to make levels and share them
and they've shared two million levels
with each other and it's cool and it's
awesome it's a huge trend and it applies
in in surprising places so one of the
things coming technologically is cloud
gaming and so on live is one of these
and the whole idea is you don't have to
have a graphics computer in your house
anymore
you hit the jump button Boop and like a
signal goes up to a remote server that
renders like the next frame and then
video streams it to you and so the
graphics computer is far away and you
don't have a computer to upgrade and
deal with all that crap and you're
playing somehow magically at a distance
and it's if it works it's really really
cool now some people criticize cloud
gaming and they say wait a minute wait
I'm not sure this is gonna work they say
on live is kind of like wine in a box
right so you think about wine in a box
for a second how do wine connoisseurs
feel about it they say no no I want wine
in a bottle just like game connoisseurs
will say no no I must have crisp
graphics I need to have them right here
I need high / low latency you know I
can't have a network latency we want to
hit the jump button that's not gonna
work so they want wine in a bottle so
now what about people with less money do
they want wine in a box they're like no
we want beer right and just like the
game people like now I could play
bejeweled or Tetris
that's fine I'll need to be graphics
computer I could play it on my watch you
do do you know and so they don't need it
they want beer
so who the heck is wine in a box for and
a cloud gaming may fall into that but on
the other hands I'm watching what the
OnLive guys are doing and it's really
smart and you look at their menu about
all the things you can do most of them
are about sharing so one of the things
you can do in these things is you log on
and it's like Boop here's all your
friends and here's the games they're
playing right now want to watch one of
them see what they're doing you can't do
that in a normal game console but you
can here because it's just sending video
streams if it sends it to one person or
ten people or a hundred thousand people
it doesn't care so it adds this new
realm of sharing that wasn't there
before so that's worth thinking about
and a couple more trends one of them
quantitative design the nature of game
design is fundamentally changing it used
to be we did things by gut feel and
design principles more and more now that
we're able to pull so much data from the
players live people are just using
numbers so they're like gee you know how
how many how many hit points should this
weapon do I don't know put out two
weapons and like see which one is
working better and they just put them
both outs and then they look oh the
people you know people who have this
many are buying the weapon more you know
let's make it be six hit points instead
of four hit points and so they're
studying the numbers and in analyzing
the how people are playing and tuning
based on that as opposed to as opposed
to just using gut feel and the companies
that are figuring this out are really
jumping ahead Zynga appears to is
something they're really really into and
it's I love the book good to great talks
about you know I was waste around a good
business and one thing it points out is
businesses that become really great they
find concrete numbers to judge
themselves by and so that sort of hmm
maybe I should be finding concrete
numbers to judge my game by so we're
seeing that now for people who are
aficionados of Candyland I place this
extreme extrinsic rewards right where
the molasses swamp is and and for good
reason this is what everybody wants this
was a little ad I found certainly
everyday things you do into the dream is
perks and rewards with a
any Rewards Visa Card and that's what we
want the gold gamification of life is
all the ordinary thinks you do Bing Bing
Bing you're gonna get rewards and it
makes it better
and isn't that nice and wouldn't that be
cool if we could measure everything and
give rewards for all the right stuff
what if we could I don't know if people
know Christopher Alexander he's the
greatest genius of the 20th century and
what if we took his 15 principles of
architecture and life and what if we
could measure every building and every
structure on that and give points for
that or if the way you rearranged your
house or or like this guy right I was
like what GK Chesterton said you know
the problem with Christianity is no
one's ever tried it well what if we had
an easy way to kind of give you points
and ratings about hey you know you're
doing good Christian ethic that's a good
behavior would that make things better
well alfie kohn says hell no and anyone
who's anywhere near this space should
read the book punished by rewards which
is all about the facts that study after
study after study shows that if you
bribe someone to do something they come
to hate that thing and this goes for you
know getting a gold star in school or
getting a performance-based incentive at
work that these things all tear you down
and this has huge implications for game
design I wish the psychologists could
have told about told us about this a
long time ago but I don't know what's up
with the psychologist quite frankly they
either don't understand about how to be
helpful with entertainment or they don't
care and if you don't believe me I've
been to their parties it stands to
reason if they know so damn much about
the human mind their parties would be
freaking awesome
anyway so but there is hope here right I
know people have seen this couch to 5k
it's awesome it's a very simple plan for
like you don't run but you'd like to run
a 5k the couch to 5k plan is here's what
you do the first day here's what you do
the second day here's what you do the
third day and it works
this simple graded system like the first
day you're just real simple you're gonna
walk for like 20 minutes and or not even
that they like you're gonna want for
five minutes and they make it real real
simple so the steps are clear and
achievable and you get progress and it
totally works because they've kind of
broken it down and and in a very
interesting kind of gamified way and
that totally works and so if you're
gonna make these systems where you're
trying to kind of add game principles
and reward principles if you do these
four things it's you're probably gonna
do it right if you make it so the thing
you're doing is engaging in other words
it's not an extrinsic reward anymore
it's an intrinsically rewarding thing to
do then that's a win for you you need to
make it effortless if people have to
like do work and fill out a card or like
pull out their phone and hit a button
there's something to kind of play your
game that's a problem but if you can
make it so they do almost nothing and
like it works
that's what's so awesome at airline
miles you one time you sign up for thing
and then the rest of the time you know
what you do is buy a ticket and being
being being being points in Awards and
it just happens it's effortless you've
got to make them unchi Noble you've got
to make them on cheetah ballif you can
somehow cheat your game life system then
the whole thing falls apart it's not
worth anything to anybody anymore and it
can't be embarrassing and people are so
easily embarrassed you might think hey
look here's a $10 off coupon at a
restaurant a lot of people are like kind
of embarrassed like oh I got a coupon at
the restaurant you know they don't
they're shy to do this sometimes so you
have to think about what's gonna be
embarrassing and a lot of times public
game play man that can be very
embarrassing and when all of those fails
personal trainers they freaking work
that's why rich people are so thin right
if you got a smart person come in your
house every day and like yeah I do this
don't do that no do this now and giving
you exactly the right coaching and
encouragement exactly the right time
just what you need it works and there's
social pressure you can't just blow the
guy off because he's like at your house
right so so there are these things can
be made to work and that's kind of the
dream if these digital systems can
become like little virtual personal
trainers that like listen and give us
just what we need just when we need it
they can change our behavior
um and so our last item here whole life
tracking this is what we're moving
towards we're moving towards a time when
every single thing we do every byte we
eat every game we play everything we do
every dollar we spend we're tracking it
we're tracking it we're tracking it and
that people are gonna start to turn it
into games and part of that's a little
terrifying and it sort of means we have
some responsibility and we need to think
about it and it means you need to look
into your heart a little bit and figure
out what the heck are you doing because
the 21st century will be a war for the
attention of humanity right and so you
have to decide what side you're on and
as far as I can figure there are four
sides in this war
one is the persuaders all these guys
care about is making money that's all
they want to do they don't they don't
care if it screws up the environment or
your life or your kids or whatever they
just want to get the money and get out
so there's those guys then there's the
fulfill errs these people want to make
people they want to fulfill people's
wishes and dreams and desires and hopes
all right that's what that's why they're
in it that's why they're making these
things then you've got the artists they
don't really care if it sells and they
don't even care if it fulfills people's
wishes necessarily they want to advance
their medium they want to kind of get
something new out there they had this
vision that they feel must be brought to
light for its own sake but then you've
got the humanitarians who want to make
things that will make people's lives
better to be able to use these new
technologies and invention to you know
help us improve physically mentally
spiritually right and so here's these
four guys and the question is who's
gonna win the war on attention in the in
the 21st century and I'll remind you of
the golden rule
one with the gold makes the rules right
and it's scary because a lot of times
you might think you're one of these
things and really someone else may be
kind of controlling you and that's a
little scary to think about and the only
way you can escape it is to wake the
hell up and think about what is going on
and what are you doing and why and it's
a question is it possible for us to like
out persuade the persuaders can we do an
end run on them right because if we can
that's freaking awesome alright but the
only way we can do it is if we wake the
hell up and we think about what we're
doing because if we can write if we can
do that then you know the game
apocalypse doesn't have to be a horrible
thing you know it could be you know it
could be kind of groovy right cuz games
are awesome right and if we integrate
all these games in our lives in like we
think it's all great and awesome I mean
that that could be good and we can get
there if you know if we become masters
of our craft or we're skilled enough to
become masters at our craft and we're
and we're wise enough to you know to
work together and we're brave enough to
kind of follow our hearts then we can
make the 21st century be a beautiful
place indeed thank you
[Applause]
I hope I didn't get you super long I
know I want to Lant astok all right
thank you
so Kevin Kelly I'm with a long now
foundation and I get to relay your
questions of which there are many this
is cozy I'm gonna go okay great I'll go
over here so you're often asked this I'm
sure but you play a lot of games do you
have a favorite game that you like to
play um Wow I play a lot again so I have
a nine-year-old daughter and so a lot of
my game playing is sort of focused on
sort of what she's into but like when
I'm all by myself there's there's a
there's a game this is my favorite game
of all time I don't even know why I talk
about this a blast core for the Nintendo
64 anybody yes I know it's stupid but
like uh it's interesting to me because
that game was not popular it did not
sell well most people looked at and were
like what is this the whole premise of
it is there's a truck with a nuclear
bomb and it's going down the highway and
oh no brakes failed and the driver
jumped out and it's like heading at a
city and the atomic bomb is active
somehow so they've they've evacuated the
city and they send you all by yourself
and your job is you must get everything
out of the trucks way and so like you
drive in in a little Dodge Dart and you
pull over and you find a bulldozer and
like you start knocking down this wall
so you can get to the train and get over
here and get the giant robot and smash
all these things and don't touch the
truck because it's gonna be a nuclear
explosion anyway I liked it a lot so
Chris sorry
says gambling is addictive as it
triggers rewards in a very engineered
semi random way will the game topple
this trigger addictive behavior is is
there something about games and
addictions that we should be woken up to
this is a really interesting thing to
think about because there are there been
people who have come out and said oh you
know this is this game addiction is a
serious thing gambling addiction can be
a very serious problem that ruins
people's lives it's weird to think about
it's just a
game that people play until their lives
are ruined
right and and some people say oh these
these these uh these massively
multiplayer games are just as bad
because if you bad game designers you
design them that way to be addictive you
make people want to keep coming back and
playing them more and more and if you
would just stop doing that the problem
will go away and that's like saying this
obesity problem it's those Baker's their
cakes are so delicious
if they would make them less delicious
problem will go away all right and so
that's obviously not realistic so it is
something you have to think about like
what is the impact that your game is
gonna have it's it's it's a difficult
it's a difficult question I don't have
an easy answer for that
so Michael M has a question many games
are short phase they can be played in a
very one sitting maybe a few hours even
sometimes or maybe a couple weeks this
is the long now foundation long term
yeah so what about very long games well
we have some like the massively
multiplayer games are certainly that way
I mean we launched toontown in 2002 it's
2010 now it's eight years and the things
still going strong and more and more
subscribers all the time it's in like
look at world of warcraft and its growth
and ten million players and it's hanging
in there is it gonna go away do you
think I don't think it's going away
which Lisa this really weird question
like what should you do with avatars
when you die maybe we'll have this
situation where we leave our avatars to
our children and they keep the
characters going and can you imagine a
situation when you're playing a
character who's like you have all those
responsibilities because you're like the
sixth generation player it's been 200
years of like of this character and it's
funny to laugh about but why the hell
wouldn't it happen I don't I don't know
I think you probably will do you think
that we're still playing some games that
have begun in previous generations right
now I like games don't have a continuity
I mean we certainly see you certainly
see some of this there's people have
these sort of games and transitions and
traditions that they sort of hand down
and you sometimes see these families
that kind of have a sports history but
this is a different this is a different
sort of thing a different level of sort
of game continuity or games last longer
than human lives can you give me a sense
of the scale of the game world I've
heard that in some ways people spend
more money on games in total than they
do on movies I don't know they certainly
do that if you look at the game market
in total it's greater than the
box-office take if you add in DVD sales
that is still bigger but games are big
us alone I think is about 20 billion
right now and it's mostly been getting
bigger each year it's also getting more
difficult to measure each year because
there's new kinds of games and you got
to add you the masks it starts to get
weird and complicated and and Zynga
won't tell you how much money they're
making and so it's it's hard to know but
it is it's it's it's large and what
about when people are playing these
these larger larger I say in terms of
the scale of production these large
open-ended games how many hours would
say the best game consumed in somebody's
life well there I mean there are people
who play 40 plus hours a week for these
games for years there are some
individuals that do they put as the
equivalent of a full-time job of work
into these games and play them for years
and years and years so this happens you
know but it's kind of those are kind of
extreme cases but for some people it
becomes their primary hobby do you see
that continuing is that it do you see
sort of more professional game players
in that sense most of those guys are not
professional but there are professional
game players just like there are
professional athletes we see it a little
less in the US but in Asia it's a big
thing there are people who make you know
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
dollars a year being successful
tournament game players I mean I think I
think we are going to see a little more
of that and it's funny how we so quickly
like we take video games and we draw a
line around it and we call it games but
and we think oh wouldn't that weird
someone got money
playing video games that's so strange
but then you go over and look at sports
some dudes playing with a ball right and
it's like oh yeah he got a million
dollars sure yeah he's really good at
throwing that ball and it goes right in
the circle you know and we think that's
totally normal just because we're used
to it so over time as games change I
think people will get more acclimated to
it if we can work out that whole Monday
and Imagineer thing I don't know so can
you explain this is a question from
Eleanor Eaton can you explain the
success of these multi player online
games like World of Warcraft for those
who donates understand why yeah they
will consume 40 hours a week all right
buddy's life so part of it is their
massive scale and scope there's so much
to do it's hard to run out of things to
do there's that there's the fact that
they continue to give you goals and
goals and goals and goals and so many of
us are hungry for some kind of you know
a goal that they can achieve and it's
tangible and the goals are laid out
carefully so that they are very
achievable and you can reach them and
you get a continuing measured sense of
I'm getting better and better and better
and that's one thing we want but then
the most important factor is social
social factors the thing that makes
people stick with these things you meet
other people online you help them with
things that they seem to care about and
you end up quickly with social debt
social obligations where people need you
to come on to help them do a difficult
mission because they're trying to level
up too and you start to kind of get this
so partly it's a happy social thing like
it's nice to get together and partly
it's a oh I told them I'd come on so
alright I'll do it so it's it's many
factors they try to put as much as
possible in there and is is this
gamification of the world that you're
seeing is it seemed to me that that
advertising played just a huge role in
both you're worried about it and maybe
even the possibility of it happening
yeah do you have an alternative vision
where advertising doesn't play as big a
role in in in the in life or
games can you imagine any of this
happening without advertising I kiddin
man I mean these things can happen
without advertising but it's so natural
like the people who have the most like a
toothbrush game on its own it's not
gonna be fun enough that I'm gonna get
you to buy it right you're not gonna buy
it because it's like oh man I cannot
wait to go and like get win that
toothbrush game right you don't care
enough to play it but the toothbrush
companies will care a lot and so I think
a lot of what's gonna happen is there
are these games that they want you to
play that you might no longer play
yourself so I mean it's hard for me to
see how advertising isn't advertising
oriented games or not I mean they see
them on their rice now I mean I get
calls from advertising agencies just
constantly like oh you know we're trying
to we're trying to figure out how to
make a game out of this and that because
they want to incentivize behavior so
advertising is very common on TV and not
so common in games right now do you
think it's a good thing that kids are
spending more time playing games and
less time watching TV is is playing
games better for kids than TV it's a
very it's a very difficult question I'm
always hesitant to kind of condemn
anything outright I mean I watched it on
TV when I was a kid that's why like oh
but and and I think and I'm like man
what a waste of time that was and I'm
like no I used a lot of that to think
about things and used it as an anchor
but now is does that mean everybody's
thinking when they're watching TV I
definitely have a gut feeling that
you're more cognitively engaged when
you're playing games of almost any kind
then when you're watching most
television and so I suspect that on
average it's better but it's really hard
to say it's hard to measure it's hard to
measure these things I mean people's
criticisms are all the kids just sitting
there I'm like yeah I know he's reading
a book I mean oh my gosh and he looks at
this piece of paper and he stares and
dear and sometimes he life just moves
what is this you know but no we think
that there's something more than these
are these are difficult questions to
answer here's a question from Brian
[ __ ] what impact if any do you believe
that games can have on politics in law
oh that's a good question people have
already done some experiments in this
area making games that are trying to
influence people's behavior and I think
the closest the best shot games have it
having a meaningful influence there is
one of the things games are really good
at is making you understand complex
systems books are bad at teaching you
complex systems because books are
necessarily linear like if I want to
teach you about the workings of modern
oh the human circulatory system or the
slant-6 engine right I can try and have
a book go piece by piece but if you have
like a working version of it that you
can play with you're gonna understand it
so much faster and so many of the
decisions that people in law people in
politics have to make are about complex
interconnected systems so a game we made
at it started at Carnegie Mellon
University I was a game called it was
called peacemaker and ended up the
students who made it spun off a company
impact games was all about this and the
idea of the game was to simulate the
israeli-palestinian conflict and the
idea was to take it to the high-school
students in those countries because what
they found was the high school students
and many other people had very
simplistic views of the conflict their
conflict there their view often was well
if the guys on the other side would just
stop being jerks this whole thing would
go away and so they made a simulation
and it's like okay now you can be you
know the Palestinian president or the
Israeli Prime Minister you can be on the
other side try that out see how that
works for you and they played the game
they're like oh look at all these forces
and factors and oh man no if I do that
my people are gonna oh and they come
away like oh this is way more
complicated than I thought and then
eventually they start to plain say
I guess you can get to peace but man
it's a hard road you got to do this and
this and this and this and it was
eye-opening and engaging so I think
there is potential there but man it's
not easy making those simulations so
speaking of sort of battles and games
giver read the book Ender's Game oh yeah
certainly interesting so I just a
personal observation because this
audience may appreciate that
I personally believe if you've read
Ender's Game and then you've read
everything else that Orson Scott Card
ever wrote he sold his soul for that
book if you go back and read that book
this book written in the early 70s it it
it predicts I am it predicts blogging it
predicts people in dorms like you know
pranking each other's desktops it's an
insane amount of things that he just
nailed so right and it's such a
beautiful story for people who haven't
read it the whole idea of it is that the
the perfect general has total empathy
because they're able to use that empathy
to understand the mind of their opponent
but of course they need to destroy that
opponent which is going to make them go
insane and that's like the whole
fundamental anyway it's a beautiful book
but we have a little bit of a sense of
the Ender's Game actually with the
drones in Afghanistan right and the
gamification of war is that does that
fit into your scenario very much oh my
gosh I mean so much stuff is happening
in terms of simulations simulations are
turning the military upside down in in
some ways I remember being I was called
into some kind of think tank thing a few
years back because they've like the
soldiers realized that good simulations
can save their lives they know that men
are going to go on this mission we're
going to do this if I can practice with
the simulation I'm going to be better
and often they found themselves
dissatisfied with the simulations they
were provided so they're like whatever
get me some Unreal Tournament
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh I'm gonna make the
simulations myself and you know and here
you've got these you got these generals
walking around it's like what the hell
is this you're doing oh we made it
ourselves you what you you just
when made it yourself and you're making
decisions that we didn't come from the
top down and in the middle of a
discussion like some people were really
like yeah this is great it's gonna
democratize the military right and the
generals are all in one and one of the
older guys in the room says let me tell
you something in all of history there's
only been one young wise man and he got
nailed to a tree anyway so simulations
really are starting to make a big
difference and in ways it used to be the
mill the military invented real-time 3d
graphics so they could do this stuff
now they buy it from game companies
because game companies have more money
than they do I don't even like to think
about that so you talked a little bit
about intrinsic rewards and the
punishment of rewards here's a question
from Michael Kim what's your view on the
dichotomy of bouncing extrinsic rewards
versus interest rewards when it comes to
game fiying personal experiences right I
mean the thing to understand about
extrinsic rewards is they are they are
fleeting they are temporary people will
do them as a novelty and they quickly
get really sick of them the experiences
that last long terms are ones that
people will find intrinsically rewarding
and this is the thing the advertisers
don't get and you're gonna see so many
experiments that are gonna give you
points and prizes to do so you know in
order to get you to do these things and
a lot of them are just gonna fall flat
on their face because the the what
they're creating is not interesting
enough engaging enough meaningful enough
to you it's gonna be what would be cool
though is it'll be a huge petri dish
where we're gonna see thousands of
experiments and the clever and wise ones
will survive and lots of them will die
in the process and what motivated you to
get into games you mentioned the number
of hours you spent watching TV was there
something else
did you play a lot of games as a kid I
played a lot against I've always been
fascinated I guess I've always been
fascinated with anything that seemed
magical and games are freaking magical
you know you look at a game of Monopoly
or something now what do I got I got a
lump of cardboard I got like some
rainbow fake money I got these little
metal things and then like suddenly
we're having a fight right and I'm like
I got the dice and I'm sweaty I'm like I
hope I don't land aboard whoa oh my god
oh my god right and all these emotions
came out of this this these little
things in this little set of rules and
that always seemed like incredibly
magical to me so that's that's that's
partly you know what's always fascinated
me about games and there will be more
magic in games oh sure and technology
lets you have things that are just I
mean that's one of the great things you
know we've made the making making thing
we put these things in the theme parks
and such and people come and they're
like I what is that possible I didn't
know you could do that and it's and
that's that's one thing I love - I
didn't I didn't know this was possible
like in that Toy Story Mania for for
Disney World we made the opening scene
there's a thing happens in the opening
scene of it doesn't happen anywhere else
where the characters invite you to throw
pies at them and you have this pie
launcher and you're shooting pies and
the characters look like they're
pre-rendered I mean incredibly
high-quality and like and they react so
what you do they're like hey come on
whoa and like if you aim at their face
they let go they block with it and
there's a moment where people like wait
wait what
that animated characters reacting to
what I do and there's that magic moment
where I can't I can't believe this is
happening is as I like I like that
moment I really appreciate the magical
evening you've given us and I want to
thank you for your wonderful time here
all right well thank you very much
you
[Music]
you